in five four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius brain podcast I am your host
David so I'm your other host Joe Jitsu
cow up a bit baby but the baby baby well
well well well what have you been up
there dude ah
uh what have I been up to man there's a
lot going on in my life right now about
to go to Europe in a week oh do you're a
traveling man did your you're a
different man
it's one of my life bucket lists and you
and you know what's crazy the happiest
point of my life I made this commitment
it was like 2018 or some [ __ ] like that
I was like no no this was 2015 I don't
know man
my dates are all [ __ ] up 2018 was a
year ago yeah what was five years ago
what's the word 2020 so 29 2015 2015
right yeah I made a goal this is around
the time I met jazz my ex I made a goal
that every month I'm gonna be traveling
somewhere I don't know where I'm gonna
go like I remember that yeah yeah and I
did it and that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] fun
dude
so um and then when we got into the
relationship and we got really busy from
work and just life happened we still
traveled like I think we still travel
more than the average person travels
like we're hell a blast like we're hell
yeah we're lucky you know but there's a
difference between work traveling and
just traveling probably for sure dude
yeah when we were traveling before like
for example to like people understand it
goes oh you want to go to Japan again
for a third time
well the first time that we did it was
in like a 20-person setting yeah second
time we did it it was literally for work
it was poor yeah we went to go visit our
farms so it's like a work Asian mm-hmm
which is a little bit different yeah to
me is a lot different yeah cuz and then
on top of that so like the third time I
just want to go just to explore and I
want to be there for two weeks I think
when you travel - yeah it's hard to
explore even a fraction of like people
people you have to realize - you live in
a city - where you're at and then you
still haven't even explored that within
the 30 or 20 years that you lived so how
hard it would it would it be to explore
a whole country within a week yeah you
can't and then you don't want a rush
thing
you don't want to be like all right
we're gonna do ten items in this city
and then we're gonna take a train and go
to this city and you just run so damn
fast that you don't get to marinate and
I like to marinate you know yeah
cuz I I know that man Japan is so much
stuff to offer man if you guys have a
bit of Japan first of all that country
is the nicest country I've ever been to
in my life like people are so [ __ ]
nice over there in terms of like service
and also to because our dollar is more
than theirs because their economy tanked
so rich well if you go to the
countryside they're even nicer cuz
Tokyo's like the New York of Japan so
they're actually mean oh really that's
considered mean that's considered mean
by Japanese standards cuz holy [ __ ]
right they're too busy you know whatever
like you got to go to the countryside
you got to go to the suburb I mean Kyoto
is a more countryside I guess but it's
touristy yeah very pristine and in like
so yeah you'll you were we went to was
pretty touristy but then if you go to
the countryside and all that Okinawa
Hokkaido all that like the north all
those areas are supposed to be really
chill like my brother did a whole
backpacking trip from top to bottom
Wow north to south and he was like yeah
what's the what's the what's the age gap
from you and your brother 12 [ __ ] yeah
so well beers was he was but I always
I'm always curious with like people who
have like older brothers cuz my cousin
his older brother is also about 10 to 12
years and he was very like omnipresent
like he wasn't really there yeah I think
the reason why we're not close to is
because he is he went so like since he's
12 years older than me and he went to
boarding school when do you when you
start your high school around like 14
right yeah so 14 or 15 when they had me
things got busy my parents were both
working my brother started acting up so
they sent him to boarding school in high
school oh holy [ __ ] so as soon as I was
like 3 or whatever he's gone for 4 years
home soon so when I'm 7 or he'll come
back maybe to visit in the summer or
whatever we might see him but I'm like I
didn't see him until I was 7 or 8
damn yeah and then he lived at the house
for about a year to go to Community
College so that's the most time I've
known him is for a year and then he
would take me skateboarding that's when
like I remember him fixing motorcycles
and [ __ ] and then he would put me on the
back of his bike and we're like Japanese
hillbillies dude like this we we [ __ ]
gunned it down the street no helmet and
he would do donuts and destroy people's
front lawn and yeah man it was funny
like looking back now that was some
dangerous [ __ ] yeah yeah I remember one
time I got my ass beat because I was
like 9 or 10 and I wasn't big enough to
take his bike out but I literally like
picked it up and I turned it on and in
the bike fell and I couldn't get it back
up and he was pissed
oh but yeah he dropped it yeah yeah
that's the most fun I had and the most
interaction that I've had with them
because he was hella into like just
redneck [ __ ] you know like mortar sports
skateboarding surf feeling your brother
just very active people he's way crazier
than I am
I'm monastery cat compared to him yeah
he's like the extreme sports guys that
can actually do the tricks I can't do
any other tricks oh yeah so like I'm not
a I'm not really a daredevil like him
like he did the competitions he did
those you know when you go snowboarding
with this guy he's flipping around and
doing the 360s and [ __ ] and I'm just
riding that's so interesting cuz like I
feel you would think that maybe because
when I see like some relatives I usually
see like the older or the the younger
brother and the younger brother being
different right yeah I could tell like
they have like distinctive personality
differences but you're just like a like
a not as I guess bald version of him in
terms of like extremes oh yeah no not
even I wanted to be like him and I would
kind of mimic him but he is a
interesting case like I remember the
last time we had a we talked and we were
talking about like our our selves and
just whatever we had we share a lot of
similar personality traits in how we
view the world and how we
Society and all this other stuff but
when it comes down to how we play it out
um it's completely different because I'm
an extrovert like a [ __ ] right
like I love audiences I love people I
love going out talking to others making
friends he's like I'm a severe introvert
he's like I want a cabin in the woods
kind of guy Oh didn't you tell me one
time he this will got lost in a forest
yeah that was in Japan so when he was
doing a tour in Japan he he was with the
tour group and he kind of I don't think
he's a TD but he he's kind of like that
kid that follows a butterfly everywhere
so he's taking photos and stuff and he's
going into the forest and he and he
basically loses the tour group and he
goes deeper and deeper and he says he
starts finding these little what do you
call them they're they're like shrines
are like little stone statue things
right oh yes yes yeah yeah we saw that
in the countryside yeah like they have
little fox or like little buddha guys or
whatever he's like that's tight so you
take some picture and he goes to another
oh that's tight right and before he
knows it he's like hole crap I don't
know how to get back so he's he's he's
lost in the forest in Japan and in the
[ __ ] sun's about to go down so he's
running and looking around and he's like
holy crap right he doesn't know what to
do and then he sees light and he follows
it and he gets into this village and
then he kind of finds a guy walking in
village and he tells him like yeah I'm
completely lost this is what happened
and a village guy was like oh [ __ ] that
sucks and he goes come over and then his
he told his whole family and then they
basically gave him a room fatum bate let
him bathe and then in the morning they
took him to the but they walked his ass
all the way to the bus station and then
pretty much like did all that Japanese
people are so [ __ ] a nice dude if I
saw somebody in the middle of a forest I
mean like [ __ ] you you're gonna murder
me dude
but he probably cuz he knows that my
brother's coming he speaks Japanese - so
probably different from like who's this
but they'll probably do it for a
foreigner - so crazy but that's country
people right and I feel
like country most country people all
over the world are really good like
kind-hearted Souls dude I could not get
lost in the forest I would [ __ ] die
dude I would literally [ __ ] die
that's not the first time you got lost
in a forest oh why is he keep going in a
forest what's wrong with him so he was
like he was telling me that he was like
very since he was so introverted he
hated being a little [ __ ] about
everything like yeah and he said okay I
have to travel alone because he was
scary because he used to travel with
people all the time so he says maybe in
Japan I can do this
so he decided that he was gonna go
backpack in Japan and do this by himself
and then after that he was like I always
want to travel alone [ __ ] people because
he's like people dragged me down I have
to negotiate and be like you want to eat
this you want to go there and people
were like nah and he's like well [ __ ] I
don't want to listen to that I want to
go where I want to go so he stopped
traveling with people Wow
I can't I can't imagine not traveling
with somebody me too I love the
experience I like sharing the experience
with each other and they're gonna talk
about it when we come after like that's
what I like about traveling yeah like
doing it by myself
it seems so empty to me well I'm going
to Europe by myself but I'm meeting
someone there oh yeah yeah that's one
yeah cuz yeah I'm shot house to Kylie
like he's a vlogger out in Vietnam and
he's kind of he's gonna show me the
ropes out there Europe my friend told me
that when I go to Vietnam I'm gonna look
like a [ __ ] giant oh dude you are
Vietnamese people are small man did I
already know what that's like because in
Japan I felt like I was a giant yeah I
was I remember that the subway handles
it was like right at my nipple no
they're smaller yeah then Japanese
people the younger generation isn't
though okay but for the most part I
think everyone's just smaller like but
you know our buddy TK that owns a club
out there he's like six something yeah
he's tall as [ __ ] you something tall
like he's towers man yeah and it's so
funny cuz all the girls just like they
look at him like oh my god look at his
tall drink of water
it is me and [ __ ] Danny are standing
behind of like these two [ __ ] guys
you know like it looks American look at
those nutrients is his body know he had
an American diet
I want the past mark that's great do you
feel do you feel like you're I'm I don't
want to say that you've missed out on a
lot but you know within the five years
that you were together with just like
you you really didn't get to do or I
felt like you weren't doing the stuff
that you wanted to right just because
you know you guys were so different in
terms of like traveling experiences you
know for her I mean like a lot of people
don't know this about her but when she
travels like she gets like huge [ __ ]
migraines yeah it's very debilitating
for her you know I think like when
you're with somebody like that too and I
didn't experience you know that level of
stuff but recently Muriel has been
Merida was going through a stint where
she wasn't very motivated and I kind of
felt a little bit of that where I felt
guilty for wanting to leave an
experienced life with a man that's what
I was going through yeah because um I
shouldn't feel this way I feel like
because she wasn't trapping you in that
it's not her fault
yeah yeah so sometimes what will happen
is um so I didn't know this but Bart
gets airplane migraines - oh so he was
relating to Jess about this but just get
some severely so it's like it's like the
the what do you call it like the height
the being up in the air tightness the
whatever and then the going up and down
and levels I some people are affected by
the others aren't but then um Jess
sometimes gets it to the point where she
can't even walk because she's puking so
we get to places you know we have to use
the whole entire first day to just chill
yeah and my personality is you know I'm
a fidgety [ __ ] yeah
and I get crazy so I'm like I gotta go
dude and she's like um can you get me
medicine and I'm like oh hell yeah I'm
gonna go get you medicine yeah you get
the [ __ ] out of this hotel right yeah so
I get out and I'm exploring but at the
same time I'm like oh but I feel so bad
like I should be there with her so it
was a struggle man because a part of me
is like I want to share this experience
with her but the other part of me is
like
wanting to be a [ __ ] Indiana Jones
adventurer yeah and then we both have
different likes and dislikes and energy
levels like she really likes to chill
take things slow do things like on a
resort and relax and for me I'll relax
when I get home I just want to see
everything and move and and and for me I
don't get tired on trips cuz it's so
energizing to me but I know for some of
my friends like and especially like with
just two trips exhausting so they need
to have a recharge day yeah and I think
for me I wasn't really a good boyfriend
in that sense where I knew how to
balance that I would just get pissed
like why are you tired were all vacation
you know yeah I think I mean I wanted to
say you were a bad boyfriend in that
it's just more like you know I I
mentioned this where I said that there
are certain things that people have
within a relationship that there that
there's their pillars I call them
pillars it's like these are stuff that
cannot be removed or my foundation of as
a human being broken one of your pillars
is how you experience life yeah and I
think with her it was frustrating
because you want to take her along but
she can't yeah and so it's just at first
it's like okay I feel bad then it's your
- same thing you're three same thing
yeah builds up builds up and you get a
little bit of resentment in there yeah
and it's just both of you start to
present each other and it's just coming
from it's weird because it's coming
still coming from a good place it's like
I wish that you could do this with me
not [ __ ] you I want to bounce it yeah
I'm so frustrated because I want to
share the experience and we can't just
cuz you know like at the end of the day
we're just two different people and we
want different things out of a vacation
and I didn't realize how important that
was
to know that stuff before you get into a
relationship with someone yeah like you
got a test like how you both experience
and explore a vacation cuz these things
like who the [ __ ] knows until it happens
you wonder there's so many divorces in
our parents generation they just [ __ ]
get married and then they they find this
[ __ ] out later and they're like ah [ __ ]
they have people who jump the gun and
they get together really fast with
people and they get infatuated with this
concept like this fairytale relationship
concept a lot right yeah because
everybody's on a high when they first
start and you think
that glimpse of happiness is something
that's going to show what your whole
future is gonna be yeah it's not the
[ __ ] case
yeah because even with your friends you
you really don't even know who your
friends are until you spend time with
them yeah it's not even in the first
year second third fourth and then you're
like oh [ __ ] this guy you want to get
away yeah there's there's been a lot of
times to where we see friends where they
assume that they know these people and I
and I use these words friends very
loosely because I have Tim says it the
best he goes there's homies and there's
the homies you know I mean I said I have
friends and I have homies yeah yeah and
Sunnis are like that's family yeah
exactly friends are like acquaintances
that's what most people call them cuz we
got a lot of acquaintances and friends
yeah it's just you know how many people
are the homies where it's like I can
literally toss you my house key and be
like enter whenever you want yeah you
know and then they'll have enough like
common sense to know when they can come
in when they shouldn't that's that's the
type of level of connection that I feel
like that's what real friends are yeah
and that's the hard part where people
get confused like yo this is my friend
are they [ __ ] really though nope are
they really and people don't know how to
filter people for you mm-hmm like their
[ __ ] like yeah he's my friend
and then you think that they're vouching
for them and then you get [ __ ] over by
this friend of theirs and you're like
what the [ __ ] man he goes oh well I
didn't know it didn't call him your
friend you [ __ ] yeah exactly it's oh
man I remember this time worm so I was
in Riverside and I don't think people
really understood what I meant by like
is this a homey or not right so it's
like there was this dude his name is
James and James is a very very rich rich
[ __ ] Chinese kid like now he's like
this rich Taiwanese kid and this fool
was he was just like an acquaintance
friend right and when I told people when
we were living in that apartment it's
like when people come over they have to
be somebody that I know and I wanna I
wanna you know I got to know them
obviously you don't want to bring
everybody in your house yeah but [ __ ]
rich [ __ ] kids they don't know [ __ ]
yeah they just let anybody walk into
and they are they're the ones that
should be the most paranoid I don't know
why every single [ __ ] like rich kid
that I've known let them in I say let
the [ __ ] they'll let a [ __ ] predator
in their house and say oh he's cool
mm-hmm and they'll be shocked what [ __ ]
goes down yeah and so I I hated that
[ __ ] behavior and there's like
another story to that too but this one
so this dude number one I said like okay
one of my roommates basically led him
into the apartment right and I don't
really know that dude like that which I
don't really [ __ ] like and I you know
when they when he came in I was like
cool he goes yo can my homies come in is
what somebody typically should ask
before they come in if you're already
loud in you bringing some other people I
don't know is not [ __ ] allowed yeah I
don't know them I don't know where
they're at I don't know who they
associate like a three-way [ __ ]
exactly so he comes in and this is like
some [ __ ] where he comes in and he
starts uh I had a roll right just didn't
like the smell of [ __ ] weed I hated
that smell so I was like because it
stinks up the whole house like she's
just somewhere else yeah but that full
broke up a [ __ ] black and milds
use the [ __ ] rap and started smoking
it's not our place and I came after
class into the apartment to find this
fool with a bunch of tobacco on the
floor on the table and all read these
[ __ ] were smoking my apartment
oh I didn't know two of them and I just
knew James yeah and looked at James was
like James yo what the [ __ ] are you
doing yeah and he goes nah man it's cool
it's cool why is it cool I don't know
but he said and then I just wanna call
it's not cool but this is I guess that's
how rich [ __ ] kids work or some [ __ ]
I don't know if someone said what the
[ __ ] you have to answer them you don't
tell them that it's cold yeah it's cool
it's cool like that's gonna defuse it
that's only gonna make me want to murder
them yeah so I got really [ __ ] angry
it's the funny thing too so two of his
homies are like his frat homies or
whatever right and I literally looked at
James slap the [ __ ] Greek letters off
their shirt what the [ __ ] so these pills
are just said you know I was like yo you
two got to get the [ __ ] out of my
apartment right now James let me talk to
you real quick right I was like yo I
don't even like you being in my
apartment alone in the first place like
number two because I didn't L say it was
cool like my other roommate said it was
cool you don't ever bring [ __ ] random
people in here right he goes nah man
you're tripping it's cool and it was
literally [ __ ] grabbed him by his
[ __ ] Pat Bell
and I flip them and I slam them on the
floor I was so [ __ ] angry and I
started like choking this full out on
the floor
you're tripping it's cool why would you
say that because someone and he just
kept on making me angry but this guy
James is so [ __ ] dumb and so high I'm
literally choking this full out and I
let him up right and he goes it's
already been done you idiot and he goes
David David David I'm like what's up
right piss and he goes do my phone is
dying maybe you got a charger like he's
so [ __ ] high he doesn't know what's
going on he's like do you have a charger
because my phone is dying I immediately
stop getting angry because I couldn't
like your new ship must be laced with
something because you're out of this
[ __ ] universe right now you don't
even realise that I just slammed you to
the floor he realizes that he was like
he said do you have a charger my phone
is dying why I just land the man was
choking him on the floor
it was so [ __ ] and these two other
dudes that were in the frat pissed me
off so much because they started after
they heard us the commotion go ahead and
they started coming in and my other
buddy Rishi he was like you guys just
stepped out cuz names gonna [ __ ]
murder you right now cuz they're like oh
[ __ ] cuz I James already didn't get
[ __ ] socked in the face because I
know him yeah these two other people who
I don't know that it's just started
[ __ ] smoking of blood in my place I
would have stabbed him I was so [ __ ]
mad but that's that's just like people
are weird it's like you're not close
enough to me yeah to be doing this [ __ ]
you understand like they don't
understand that [ __ ] they probably treat
it as a crack house they're like it's
cool welcome to the crack house you know
I know I think when I first moved to
Riverside that was the first time I
lived outside of my house
so I didn't really I didn't have enough
Excite personal experience with other
human beings to really learn how to
control my temper when things wouldn't
go my way yeah you know and I was living
in a house with people who had all
different walks of life and I'll be and
most of the people in that place except
for a couple of guys this guy named
Christian and this other dude named Tony
we had similar walks of life in terms of
what we weren't ballin you know but a
few of them were pretty [ __ ] well-off
and those are the ones I clash with all
the time cuz we didn't have the same
wavelength yeah we had a
roommate who brought in one of his
friends from the East Coast and she went
out to uh Ivy League she was she grew up
and she was living in a super nice area
like the richest area of that of that
place and then when she was at Princeton
she told me that you know they would
meet people at the coffee shop or
whatever and then they would carry that
conversation to the house like they
would bring this person that they met
like stranger and then they would bring
them to the like the frat house or
whatever house that everybody was living
in to introduce them to other people so
yeah she thought it would be a great
idea that she met someone at the spa and
bring him over to our house what the
[ __ ] yeah so like okay so this is how it
went down right that that's the back
story so I was talking to her and we
were just like where she was staying
with us for at the time she's like yeah
you know my friends gonna come over you
guys I'm really excited for you to meet
him I'm not cool what does he do oh you
know I think he's kind of like in
between jobs right now but he's like in
entertainment like so I think you'll
like him cuz it's kind of like the same
thing and I'm like oh really yeah but he
doesn't have a car so we have to go pick
him up and I went wait why does his LA
he's in between jobs he doesn't have a
car that sounds like a [ __ ] loser to
me yeah and he's kind of an
entertainment that sounds like a wannabe
yeah like everybody here is kind of in
entertainment yeah that to me just is a
guy who's just he thinks he's a [ __ ]
singer or a rapper or actor or whatever
right yeah [ __ ] loser and then um I
was like so how long you known this guy
like is he from the East Coast and he's
visiting and she's like no and I'm like
oh like where'd you meet him Oh at the
spa like a week ago we just been talking
what the [ __ ] and I'm like no you ain't
gonna go [ __ ] get him what are you
talking about like you know crazy
because no he's cool he's my friend your
friend you just met the [ __ ]
exactly so so then like I I told her
like you can't [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
right
and when I made this realization it was
it was like it was like it kind of like
oh wait a minute I didn't [ __ ]
realize this like they're already on
their way and I called her and I was
like hey you can't do this [ __ ] right
yeah and then later they that's when I
found out why she thinks this way is
because when she went to Princeton I
kind of told a story out of order but
was she you know she's like well I
didn't think you'd be any like harm
because she did that all the [ __ ]
time like they do that [ __ ] in those
rich college towns so I'm like if I knew
this when I was a criminal yeah I would
have I would have went to a coffee shop
in Princeton [ __ ] made friends walked
into one of those [ __ ] billionaire
frat houses and robbed those [ __ ] dry
yeah you know it what the [ __ ] are you
guys kidding me man you that's why is it
that safe and sheltered am I the one
that's kind of like a battered housewife
here where I've been through some [ __ ]
you know what I mean like I I saw some
[ __ ] that's why I'm paranoid like I'm
not gonna let these [ __ ] in my house
yeah it's crazy even something as small
as this right so hmm stealing my all of
my $200 worth of furniture you know to
me like I don't have much to [ __ ] take
but you know it's a violation like
[ __ ] uh even Muriel too when we were
first dating there was something small a
park a car we leave and she left her
backpack in the front seat and I was
like what are you doing and she was like
it's cool we're just gonna go in for
like 10 minutes like no always take your
backpack because I'm used to people
busting [ __ ] windows and jacking back
only takes one minute to do that exactly
not even just smash grab and you're gone
and then she was like no it's completely
okay don't worry about it I'm like no
that makes me uncomfortable always take
your bag with you or if you're not throw
it in your trunk because if people see
your [ __ ]
that means they could take it and I
think for her it was hard pressed
because she knows she grew up in like
the Chino Hills diamond but she thinks
that the window would protect it I think
like it's not just like there's no way
in she's so [ __ ] innocent yeah alive
don't worry I locked a door okay oh
great well there's no way no one's gonna
get in now a lot of people that in that
area that she grew up with
had that similar mentality they built
they don't think of like these negative
negative [ __ ] that could happen well I
would love to live in their world that's
something I think we we stay in the
wrong area food oh we should have just
went over into that area and then done
what we normally do and it would have
been okay and they wouldn't have known
any better I it's it was so real it's
just like the the upbringing is so
different even when we there was one
time Muriel and I went to the beach and
when we were going back to the car it
was the Sun was already setting I when I
was walking up I saw two dudes huddled
next to my car with the Tesla at the
time and they were huddled next to it
doing some [ __ ] and the first thing I do
I walk up and I literally push Muriel
side and I walk up my yo what's up these
kids they get the oh I'm so sorry that
they were changing their clothes in
between our cars because they're going
to the beach and the Mariel was like
well she was like why did you yell at
them like that I was like whoa where I
grew up
if somebody's huddled next to my car
they're trying to bring in the trying to
jacket and she goes I can't believe you
would think like they would ever do
something like that
and I was like what's she thinking like
you were treating them a certain way
because of the color of their skin well
they were just there were some white
boys but she thought that I was being
hyper aggressive but what I was trying
to explain to words that this usually
meant my shits gonna get Jack as my
car's been broken into a couple times
yeah just like that yeah and it was just
weird and I kind of felt bad because I
kind of like squared up on them I'm not
like a scary-looking dude but then you
know I was like [ __ ] getting ready to
like protect my [ __ ] car yeah and I
think for her as she but she wasn't used
to growing up like that yeah so for her
she just sees me being hyper aggressive
she's like you're overreacting yeah a
little bit she thought I was
overreacting but in my mind I wasn't
because I thought somebody was gonna
steal my car yeah it's where the when
people grow up differently but just like
that that lens in that perspective yeah
for me I think I I've always got along
with people that grew up similar in
class then race mmm look I got along
more with white black Mexican that are
like lower middle class or whatever then
I do with Asians that are hike
yeah we had nothing to talk about ya
mean aside from the culture and food
yeah the upbringing is different like so
when people like I mean we always talk
about race and we always talk about like
in Asian culture and this and that but I
think a bigger thing that connects us
all is like class culture because I had
a lot of similarities with Jess because
of that even though she's like white and
stuff I mean she is an errand
you know he's white and like even Steve
and like we all kind of have a similar
background in class right like we're
either middle or lower to middle class
and we never really grew up like a lot
of our rich friends mm-hmm so some of
our rich friends will have will be
friends with but there's a little bit
that's a that's different if you've
noticed yeah yeah yeah yeah and and but
then as you grow up you you start
becoming more worldly right so you could
connect with more people and it but it
there is something to me that there's
just a different kind of human being
that's created especially like if if you
if you never had to worry about money or
safety mmm this podcast is brought to
you by Skillshare my friends I like to
learn I like to learn when I want to
learn and if only there was a place
where there was a library full of
thousands of videos that will help me
brush up on my hobbies or maybe even
some new entrepreneurial skills on my
free time well guess what there is it's
called skill share my friends let me
tell you a little bit about skill share
skill share is an online learning
community with thousands of amazing
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills you can take
classes in everything from photography
creative writing design productivity and
a whole bunch more this is just to name
a few so whether you're returning to a
long time passion project challenging
yourself to get outside your comfort
zone or simply exploring something new
Skillshare has the classes for you you
guys know me I'm a photo guy and you
can't do photo without a little bit of
basic knowledge and Foundation Man Adobe
Photoshop and all these other programs
actually require you to
to know these things because these
programs are not intuitive at all and I
want to know specific things and I could
pick and choose from certain courses so
I can just go right to it so Skillshare
has thousands and hundreds of classes
that that are basically at the end of my
fingertips I could just click click away
get on the website and then look for
whatever I want to learn and skill sure
has got my back so check it out join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering genius brain
listeners two months of unlimited access
to thousands of classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash brain
again go to Skillshare comm slash brain
to start your two months now that's
Skillshare dot-com slash brain yes it's
a different world they we I just came
back from a wedding and um and I only
this this only reminded me of like how
certain people who have who live in a
one area in their whole life and they
kind of they grow up well-off they kind
of just say [ __ ] without thinking about
repercussions a lot you know cuz I felt
like when we grow up if we said
something out loud in public we knew
that if we if we were like dissing
somebody or if we had like a hardcore
opinion about somebody else there's a
chance that you could get like slapped
up for it so alright cuz there's
violence involved like you offend the
wrong person like you might go through
some real crazy violence yeah yeah then
Muriel and I went to a wedding not too
long ago where I'm not sure if they're
really her close friends actually
they're not her really close friends but
they kind of know each other from in the
past and they kind of reconnected at the
wedding and I think she realized how
different she grew she grew apart from
them just based on this the subject
matter what they talk about who they
talk about and how they talk about
certain things so they kind of grow up
with just only Korean people right and
so the way they say certain things about
other races it's it's so common to like
bash on other races and you know it's
like light-hearted jokes but to me it's
not like hard because I grew up in such
a multicultural area like for example
I'm one of them and I got really quiet
and I was like man I look at I say
something but I'm like this is a wedding
and whatever this person is not somebody
I care about so I'm just gonna let it
slide but
she just says something like really
racially insensitive where she was like
oh yeah like I remember this guy that I
used to date like yeah I was really in
love with him but yeah now he's dating
like some some some ratchet girl you
know cuz like you know you know those
enemies people and I was like [ __ ] and
the first thing you know I grew up
around lot of enemies people so I kind
of like my ears perked up and I kind of
looked they were like the [ __ ] did you
say like like it was like there's you
know we make jokes about like you know
how Asian people hate other Asian races
and it's based in that comedy world but
she said it as a matter of fact like
Vietnamese people were lower than her
and I kind of like looked at her like
the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I mean like I'm
Korean but you don't know how I grew up
yeah [ __ ] watch your [ __ ] mouth
and I just kind of sat there for the
rest of the wedding I just had my phone
I was playing games
cuz like [ __ ] these people yeah I was
like I can't I can't listen to this
[ __ ] ignorant [ __ ] and it was
hard for me cuz this is definitely a
matter of people who grew up only around
their kind their thoughts their
philosophies and they're very
close-minded human beings and I'm
they're the same type of people that
would scream racism if someone did that
to them exactly
and I just like sat there and it was
kind of like doing inside me a little
bit but it wasn't it wasn't up my
wedding
it wasn't my scenario and I'm not gonna
ruin somebody's wedding and make us yeah
that's only correct if you say it in
front of a Vietnamese person yeah so you
know the people that mad no man I know
you it's only funny when you're doing it
as a joke and you don't really mean it
yeah and she meant it that's [ __ ] up
because that's the thing man it's like I
love making fun of how shitty like
different cultures are yeah but so is my
culture I'm sure you know but that
that's the joke and that's the fun part
you're saying things that you're not
supposed to say but when you really mean
it and you really think that other human
beings are below you that's such a low
way to thing and it's be and yeah it's
that's where it stemmed from it wasn't
there wasn't any nuance it wasn't really
a joke it was just like these videos
people are lower than him like ratchet
dude [ __ ] Korean people are ratchet
as [ __ ]
have you been to k-town what are you
talking about dude [ __ ] are you saying
she thinks she acts like like Christians
are super proper we have something
called Thome girls which are [ __ ]
escorts as normalizing our
culture whether you just walk around
sucking dick all day what the [ __ ] are
you talking about dude so funny look I'm
not hating on my coach I'm just saying
like every culture has their negative
thing every culture has ratchet yeah
wait buddy there there is no culture
that is completely classy and completely
like rich and and yeah like there's none
of that [ __ ] yeah that that the remark
came from just just it was like her
truth it didn't feel very much like she
was making a sigh commoner joke it was
just like a true thing it's like oh you
know that Vietnamese people are only
like this it's I know a lot of
Vietnamese people that are very classy
and very wealthy they are in Vietnam
right now dude killin it I know right
but that's that's kind of hard for me to
digest to like especially because I have
so much love for that culture or just I
know a lot so it almost feels like an
offense to me personally if they hear if
I hear [ __ ] like that like in its legit
yeah like if someone says it cuz that's
the same thing as if a white person were
saying it to a black person or whatever
it doesn't make it less because it's
Asian on Asian yeah exactly and it's the
whole it's you know when we not we you
you would do this character just like
the making the Korean character that's
making fun of other Asian race that's a
nuanced joke because of how superior
Asian people feel compared to other
alien races I'm making fun of all the
old Asian men that are just blatantly
racist but they don't realize how
[ __ ] dumb they are yeah because
they're really just the trash of that
race they think that way but you got to
understand that to get it like a lot of
these people they're probably lowest on
the totem pole in their culture and so
to overcompensate for being such a
[ __ ] lowlife they have to talk [ __ ]
about other races yeah cuz the classiest
of the classy is they're not [ __ ] even
doing that they're too busy making money
and doing crazy [ __ ] yeah you know for
facts to like you know like a lot of the
Vietnamese homies that I grew up around
or I still have to this day there's some
ratchet there's a paranormal ratchet
ivities going on as I said I mean but
that's what makes it so fun that's the
fun you know if you've never been to a
[ __ ] Vietnamese wedding you are
missing the [ __ ] out dude that [ __ ] is
the funnest wedding to ever go
and like I don't know I think ghetto or
ratchet or just all that stuff is
perspective right because there's
something about the Southeast Asian
culture that I love very different from
the East Asian culture mmm I feel like
we need to learn how to [ __ ] loosen
up talk about East Asians write Japanese
Koreans Chinese yes we party and we
[ __ ] binge drink in whatever but I
feel like we have a lot to learn from
Southeast Asians and just enjoying life
and not being so tense and not being so
[ __ ] serious there's a lot of saving
face you know in our culture's there's a
political like Korean and Japanese it's
so much ingrained into our culture it's
so hard to be yourself because you're
thinking about what somebody else thinks
about you all the [ __ ] time you're
all you're almost like living for rules
more than just living dude let me tell
you this [ __ ] punish it at that same
wedding America like we're sitting down
and this older Korean gentleman that
knew the younger girl next to us from
like at church from way before when she
was maybe he hadn't seen her maybe in a
few years I'm only guessing because the
first thing he does when he sees her he
says this he goes in Korean he goes well
you gained a lot of weight funny in
Korean culture that you know looking at
somebody and making a judgment about how
they look is completely normalized yeah
I mean a part of a Japanese to man yes
yeah she goes oh don't look those hearts
on there we'll use it oh you got a low
fat didn't you don't say that [ __ ] all
day started cracking up only because you
know from I'm Korean American from
looking at from an American perspective
I think so hurtful it be very hurtful
but it's just kind of like oh yeah I
didn't gain some weight it's like I
you're right I'm trying to lose someone
to like uh buddy plumped up yeah
but making comments about your physical
looks in Asian culture it's it's pretty
normalized I don't know what that feels
to somebody if it hurts them a lot
because if somebody looks at me and says
like oh you gained some weight it
doesn't hurt my feelings you heard it so
much or yeah maybe I just never really
felt a certain way about it because if I
did gain weight to me it's just facts
it's like same same here yeah it's like
oh you're right I did gain some weight
and I
no if it's the same in Korean but they
say it in such a cute way like the way
that they tease you and and whatever I
feel like it's adorable because ladies
too when they [ __ ] come at you and
they'll be like oh you got fat yeah no
they're not disgusted that's why it's
just yeah it's almost like a
conversation topic it's like the
immediate go to yeah one of the biggest
Korean compliments that you can ever get
is oh go or goo t weiqi Kotoka man that
which face means like oh why is your
face so small it's like you're having a
small face it's like the biggest [ __ ]
Beauty compliment you can ever get on
her it's like oh my face is small Wow
like Chia Tim's Tim's [ __ ] wife her
face is like a tiny almond een I mean in
Korea she's perfect almond face in Korea
she's considered the standard of what
beauty really cuz her face is like the
size of a [ __ ] pinkie nail yeah I
mean like I could literally cover all
Chia's face with my own I wanted to know
I mean they'll comment on all body types
right they'll be like oh you got muscles
are you tall yeah look at you you're
[ __ ] small you know like don't ya
it's just like the thing yeah that is a
that is that is a funny observation yeah
right they always have to make a
physical yeah observation about you and
that's like the beginning of their
conversation when they haven't seen you
in a long time
yeah cuz if I get fit they'll say that
too yeah like oh should you be working
out man good for you you know and
they're like yeah you been getting fat
you've been eating good yeah they'll say
that too I've uh yeah my mom my dad did
that once to this there's this kid that
I used to know in Sacramento I was one
of his first Korean friends here funny
[ __ ] because when he came to Kurt when
he came from Korea to here I can't
remember what age that I met him but I
think me was either it was definitely oh
it was freshman year of high school and
my dad is such a [ __ ] Savage because
his his older sister dressed like a
tomboy all the time like she used to
wear those baggy ass chinko jeans baggy
ass t-shirts back in the day with Korean
girls it was super popular in Korea yeah
dressing like a boy and [ __ ] in the
baggy clothes so
my dad [ __ ] comes up to this girl
right and there's like he hasn't seen
him like in a few weeks or a month or
whatever he looks at her straight up he
goes
got pretty fat it storms off it goes
super bad I just looked at my dad I was
like why didn't you say that he goes
because she got fat what's the problem
he doesn't get what the [ __ ] problem
is did it's just making that physical
observation was just something that
Korean people always do yeah he was you
got really [ __ ] fat dude he gained
weight though she got fat I thought it
was the baggy clothes okay I think she
wear baggy clothes because maybe she to
hide it to hide her oh man
that's [ __ ] uh wasn't ugly or anything
either she was I think yeah a pretty
decent looking it's just that she didn't
really she wasn't very like she dressed
very feminine I also feel like their
generation they weren't so fat like
ashamed of their fat yeah yeah like
because my uncle told me like back then
like yeah they liked slender women but
they feel like our generation is way
more body uh what's the word like
obsessed mmm like for them they're like
yeah there's like a lot of the girls now
I find completely beautiful but the guys
today don't even think so mmm so that's
one and then another thing is the guy's
body type like they're like the ideal
man was someone who kind of had a
potbelly or just had had some thickness
to them and it was like it was a
different time
and then I was asking them the the my
aunt and their the ladies of that
generation they're like we didn't want
that obviously but the guys was cool for
the guys to look that way mmm some like
really I don't know so for the guys they
wanted to be like a little bit
pot-bellied and a little bit yeah
meaty right and that was being a man
that was cool you don't want to be a
skinny boy but then the girls actually
like the skinny guys beauty standards
are so [ __ ] different dude even like
our home is when we talk about what we
like I feel like you and I have very
similar tastes in what we find
attractive right more curvy women I
think this is what we grew up seeing
athletic yeah
let a curb yeah and then you know like
some other Asian people they like the
girls with the thigh gap super thin they
look like they haven't eaten in six days
that's different yeah and they get a
hard-on looking at these girls with
[ __ ] like 12 year old boy chest
honey curves man yeah and they're like
Danis are small they have to have curves
yeah yeah and I'm you know to each their
[ __ ] own that's not really my thing
but I can't really wrap my head around
that but they can't ask their style yeah
they can't even wrap their head around
you know who I think is really pretty
well one of our friends - I remember we
were talking about it where he was like
oh who do you like who you think you're
out of your homegirls is really pretty
I think Gio is [ __ ] really really
pretty and right out of the home hungry
you know this guy specific was I I don't
really fight think she's that pretty I'm
like what and what what sense right she
goes she's just like too big I was like
too big she's [ __ ] athletic but I for
them yeah and then when I saw when I
told him to show me photos of what he
finds attractive
he likes the Asian girls that look my
little 10 year old boys like that's his
thing like he likes the super skinny you
know I mean they're very pretty in the
face but he likes them really tiny and
small I'm like well that's why you don't
think she's a very pretty girl it was
because she's you know an actual human
being like she's a size of a regular
person yeah but then I was like oh this
is this is just some different [ __ ] like
everybody has like their own flavor yeah
that's true
like for me too I think I have very
interesting beauty standards because
like me and Nicki are kind of similar in
a way where there was a name for it but
Nikki thinks human beings are kind of
blobs until someone makes her laugh
right so for me there's beautiful like
aesthetically like models you take
photos of them or whatever and then
there's there's art right and then
there's sexual like physical sexual like
like girls that do the [ __ ] TNA
modeling big-ass big titties like that
to me is just a porn realm and then you
have girls that you actually find
attractive and you desire but that takes
personality to kind of turn-on for me
and so I can have someone that isn't
really that good-looking but because I'm
into them like I think I've heard this a
lot from women - I'm like maybe I think
like a [ __ ] woman but like that
that is that is something that I'm like
boom you I want you and I will give a
[ __ ] if you look ugly to other people
you look good to me you know what it
also is - I think you know that comes
with like time and age because once
you've had this very simple form of
Attraction which is just you look good I
want to [ __ ] you yeah you're always
trying to look for that a different high
that's yeah better than in it and it's
in its to me like it's it goes away
oh very fast as soon as you get laid as
soon as the magic is gone as soon as you
start to realize their personality then
you move on to the next after a while
you get desensitized to the beauty yeah
so for example and it takes time though
cuz I'm 35 now so like it took years for
me to be desensitized to beauty and it's
only because I got laid by beautiful
girls if I never did I don't think I'd
be descent desensitized and I'll for
sure it's like once you buy a luxury car
that you can and then you can afford
another one and you can buy as many cars
as you want
and it's and then you get kind of bored
of it unless you're Jay Leno and you're
really [ __ ] into cars right but for
most people I feel like there is a point
of overstimulation and then you have to
go for something else so it's the same
thing with abusing sex it's the same
with abusing drugs I think like like
just looking at women that way it turns
into this you know it's an abusive
behavior of just looking at an eye candy
basically and there's got to be a point
where you go and grow past that but I
think for a lot of young men they get
stuck in that and sometimes forever
because most guys don't get the chance
of exploring past that and I think for
women it's different because they stand
around and they get to choose mmm like I
say a beautiful girl experiences what a
famous influencer gets to experience
yeah you know they get there they get
pursued they have choices they have
multiple choices so they could sip
can be like all right and if they wanted
to they get to experience the whole like
let's use these good-looking guys and
let's haul it up a real real quick and
see if it's worth it yeah that that that
pretty person thing gets worn out super
fast when I there's a story where when I
was in college there's one girl with in
the dorm every [ __ ] guy fond over
this chick like loved her to [ __ ]
death not because her personality was
dope not because of anything else they
just thought that she was [ __ ] hot as
hell personally didn't think that she
was that attractive but to them she was
she was like a cheerleader very fit she
was like half chinese half white a
little cross-eyed maybe that's why
didn't we like it but but they're
thinking about other things with those
cross-eyed yes I did
biggest stick the bigger their mouth
you'll probably strain it out or
something but you know being a pretty
person too I think that the the lens of
of what a pretty person sees it's so
different from everybody else too
especially because she's cross-eyed yeah
this girl I didn't I didn't it's not
that I didn't like her it's just we
didn't vibe very well because I think
she kind of predicated her personality
on her looks like she didn't really have
much to offer or talk about aside from
things about herself
it was very narcissistic right and I
didn't really blame her for that I kind
of blamed it on all the guys around her
so when she would walk into the dorm
every [ __ ] guy would act as if they
were on an island and they haven't seen
[ __ ] in years they would walk Oh how's
your day doing what are you doing today
they would they would try to make her
laugh or she would say something not
funny at all
and they're just cracking the fungi and
I was just like the [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
anemia fine anyway she was she's not
saying anything and so when I would walk
by her I would be like hey just give her
a high in a wave right and then we just
move by I would say hi and then one day
we're all chilling in the dorm and we're
all talking and then she could she could
she asked to talk to me and she takes me
aside like what's up and I'm like what's
up she goes how come you don't like me
I'm like what what do you mean I don't
like you she knows how guys actually get
hot girls yeah she goes I could tell
you don't like me and I'm like I don't I
don't know what you're talking about she
was like you don't she's like you don't
really talk to me you don't like start
up a conversation we'd like what's wrong
with me and I'm like yo nothing's wrong
with you like I'm I say hi to you every
time I see you right she goes yeah but
it's different I could tell like you
have like an attitude I'm like listen I
at that point because I had a girlfriend
at the time I was madly in love with so
I look and I'm like I'll be real with
you right she never really talked to me
after this I was like I'll be real with
you I don't know why you think you're so
[ __ ] special like I'm just I'm just
chilling like I'm just saying hi like I
know these other dudes when they come up
to you they're all like fawning over
again you're used to that attention I
don't care about you like that I don't
know you like that yeah so I'm just
gonna say hi to you like if you want to
get to know me we could be friends yeah
let's do that so she took you as being
standoffish and bad behavior because she
has a different standard of how guys
treat her exactly when someone wasn't in
love with her
which they it was yeah you're right it's
their fault because cuz they're actually
friend-zoning themselves she thinks oh
these guys are so nice and so cool we're
all friends not knowing that they all
want to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of her of
course and if you ask you she'll be like
nah we're friends no way you know and
then she sees you this [ __ ] doesn't
want to be my friend yeah and it's like
I said before I don't even blame her I
blame all those [ __ ] guys yeah ruling
over her for setting the standard of
what a normal human interaction is you
know you fell upon a technique though
that many people do not know until they
accidentally get there was what that
girl came up to you because you made her
self-conscious and that's how you get
hot girls I already had like this girl I
was in love with so I know but that's
that's that's what a lot of dudes [ __ ]
up on it is they're so [ __ ] desperate
dude yeah but I mean yeah you don't have
to be a dick just be just center
yourself yeah and then an insecure sure
you'll you'll [ __ ] make are insecure
cuz you're not [ __ ] doing what other
guys doing and you know what I think to
which which kind of hurt her feelings
the most is that you had to say like
getting so [ __ ] special though what
could that was already irritated like
I'm not special like that like you know
in college I was like I don't know and I
was you think I'm harsh now what
eighteen year old David was way worse
like I didn't give up [ __ ] yeah so now
I'm like you're not that special like I
already said all that [ __ ] but when I
look back at it the reason why I think I
was also upset was because I think she
thought fat chubby Asian dweeby guy
should be drooling over me so why is
this guy who was like geeky and fat and
weird-looking isn't drooling over me
what's wrong yeah and that already
irritated me is like [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] about you yeah you know what I
mean like I don't [ __ ] at the time I
was I was madly in love with my eighteen
year old girlfriend I was 18 we were in
love you were just a [ __ ] blip in the
radar to me
so it didn't [ __ ] matter you know and
I think it's because her her [ __ ] was
hurt because oh this guy clearly he's
gonna he's gonna be drooling over me
yeah and I didn't like her thinking that
she could had that power over me because
you don't I don't give a [ __ ] I never
really have even the first girlfriend
that I with that I was with I didn't
really like her because she was the
prettiest girl in the school I liked it
because of how she made me feel you know
she made me feel
that's so advanced you're so emotionally
intelligent I mean I grew up talking to
my mom all the time that's just a [ __ ]
like oh and you grew up in that hair
hell yeah I was wrong with my whole
[ __ ] life dude and I was too but you
were in them honey you're inside that
the difference the women are more I was
around were not the way I think they're
different man like they didn't do the
gossiping Girl Talk all that stuff my
mom [ __ ] hated gossip my grandma was
highly intelligent she was more like a
dude always wanting a debate and talk
about intellectual [ __ ] and my yeah and
my mom was just working and very like to
herself and if she goes hang out with
her friends and I'm around like they're
talking about worldly [ __ ] so I didn't
think then I didn't have a maybe a good
example of like what most women are like
you know because of the women in my
family were different yeah and they
didn't show that side to the kids which
I found out later they do they did do it
but they compartmentalised what they did
whereas in other families that [ __ ] just
went out yeah you saw mom [ __ ] you
know doing this losing her composure
doing whatever
having her period days whatever they saw
the natural forms of what a woman does
mm whereas my house they come they kept
it separate they're like don't bother
the kids don't bother the husband mm-hmm
yeah yeah man like I think I've always
liked the emotional connection because
the first time I've ever lost my the
first time I lost my virginity was with
the girl that I had been chasing in high
school for three or four years yeah so I
think like that type of sex that I had
which by the way was terrible sex uh-huh
I didn't know what the [ __ ] I was doing
she you know what the [ __ ] she was doing
I should sucked I wish it was like
Mormon [ __ ] [ __ ] threw a blanket type
of sex and like you know I mean I the
religious very strict you know like
[ __ ] to like make a child type of sex
just very boring because I don't know
what I was doing but because of that
emotional connection that I had with her
I think that was the type of high that I
was always looking for when it came to
sex because after her yeah when I I was
just like you know what dude like you
keep trying to look for a love you just
need to just date as much girls as you
can for number one for stand-up
experience so you have stories to talk
about yeah but to just [ __ ] just
start [ __ ] just try it out you know
see what happens and what I found out
too was that you know you know it was
very hard for me to get women I had to
use my mouthpiece like a [ __ ] but
when I would and I would hook up with
these girls it was like oh man it's just
it's not that good but no they're so
nice and forgiving though compared to
guys oh for sure when it comes to looks
and all that yeah I mean I mean looks is
what draws them in first but they are so
[ __ ] nice man when you think about it
the kind of [ __ ] that guy's good-looking
guys will not really do it with a good
like with a not so good looking girl
yeah like it's almost shallow yeah eyes
are much more shallow when it comes to
looks yeah cuz I think like with the
especially like the girls that I hooked
up with I think that when we made like a
good emotional connection after that it
was just it was it was are they good are
they gonna let me or not you know yeah
after a while they're having a good time
right let's [ __ ] yeah you know and he'll
it's cool cool for me I don't know about
her but it was it would happen and I
remember too when I was younger I used
to think that you know a lot of my
better looking guy friends they would
always tell these stories about you I
bag this chick I'd bag this chick but
they would never tell the stories about
how many times they tried that night and
failed mmm so I used to think that
these dudes like God I like that all the
time I remember what kleben and you saw
them talking to this one talking to that
one talking gonna that one right cuz I
didn't really like going clubbing yeah
that was like [ __ ] it after my first
girlfriend then we we separated I was
like you know what let me let me hit
this club scene to see what's up and
then I just saw them [ __ ] bomb left
and right left then right I like oh
you're not getting [ __ ] [ __ ] because
it just falls in your lap you hear ah
you swing like a [ __ ] yeah and
then you see what happens and that and
that's what's the biggest learning
moment for me I'm like oh I just gotta
keep swinging and trying and then see
what'll happen
yeah and that and that I think that was
like a really good lesson for me it's
like yo some a lot of dudes are just
full of [ __ ] yeah big time yeah and a
lot of guys I think are there more
putting on a show for the rest of us oh
for sure
cuz I'm like they probably like the Wow
more than they actually like [ __ ] the
girls I'm like what are you doing that
for they like putting the getting the
[ __ ] notch on the pegboard or
whatever I was the opposite man I was
ashamed of being such a pervert if in
your blood oh you're Japanese I know but
I thought with my dick so [ __ ] much
and then I fell in love like you know
like in without knowing I was [ __ ] my
girlfriend for a whole entire and then
she's like I don't want I don't know
like I want more others relationship and
she leaves me I'm like man [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I could get a new [ __ ] anyway and
I [ __ ] cry for a year bad for a
straight year I didn't even realize that
I was I was that's how emotionally
disconnected I was cuz every time I saw
her the only way I knew how to express
myself was through sex yeah I didn't
know how to be anything but that and I
had that that this is an ongoing thing
for the rest of my life is just I only
know how to [ __ ] yeah and that's the
only way I physically connected
emotionally or whatever I didn't say
anything I didn't express it in any
other way so for me I was just you know
I was just a barbarian is like oh I want
her and my life was ruled by my dick
everywhere I went I'm not gonna fire her
I'm gonna [ __ ] her you know like I don't
care like I don't think about if we mash
for anything I was just thinking if my
dick matched her [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's so [ __ ] funny man but for most
guys are like you though I think most
guys are I think I just will just go all
she looks good oh my god that ass I
can't stop thinking about that ass you
know I was just a hopeless romantic dude
I like that [ __ ] I think I was too until
I had a lot of hot trouble understanding
girls in that sense and I was I got my
heart broken and I was like man I don't
even want to deal with this [ __ ] and
also you know when you're young and you
know girls are young too and everyone's
young and trying to learn about
themselves and no one knows what the
[ __ ] is going on
and then I build trust issues because
you go I can't trust what these how say
[Laughter]
my [ __ ] PIM heart breaks cuz these
hoes always be lying to me my [ __ ] 15
year old self I can't trust me halls no
mom she says she loves me why she did it
you know
damn so you when you when you kind of
experience like your heartache you
couldn't really figure out what was
going on with you then huh like you
you're just hot it's just like oh [ __ ]
this pain yeah it was I was like 17
[ __ ] cry like a little [ __ ] she in
my head she left out of nowhere but
looking back there were plenty of
warning signs that she was not feeling
the relationship Here I am drunk in sex
and not knowing that I love this girl
yeah I just we were [ __ ] every week
you know you got that 17 year old boner
that needs to be handled right you
[ __ ] for a like a minute every 15 you
know minutes whatever just chilling at
home [ __ ] all the time doing nothing
you're just in bliss right
and then obviously girls are more
emotionally mature than boys are so they
want more out of it they want to think
about a future where is this going
yeah are we gonna you know be together
through hot College all these 15 years
old I'm not thinking that I'm thinking
are you coming over next week again so
we can [ __ ] yeah you know and then so
that you know we're going and we're
together for a year doing the same [ __ ]
just [ __ ] everywhere drugs together
theme parks together I'm having a blast
and then she wants out right so she
leaves and it hit me I'm like wow that
[ __ ] [ __ ] hurts like and it's in a
kid especially because it's abrupt like
kids do not know how to talk [ __ ] out
mm-hmm they make decisions in their head
and they may [ __ ] just go there's no
discussion after either yeah they just
leave it's [ __ ] hurtful right cuz it
caught me out nowhere I'm 17 16 years
old crying like a little [ __ ] while I'm
in a gang trying to pretend that I don't
have feelings it looks like a see
walking cry no [ __ ] like I will cry my
eyes out and my friends like hey man
we're gonna go [ __ ] race cars you
want to go and I'm like yeah I need
people right now [ __ ] I don't say that
right cry my eyes out like [ __ ] [ __ ]
man I got I got like borderline stalker
- I was like I'm [ __ ] I would call
and then maybe a moon oh yeah and then I
would leave a message and she wouldn't
call me back right so I'm like you know
what i'ma show her how I really feel and
I got our song and [ __ ] I would play the
song on the [ __ ] song so she would
know how I really feel I need you back
in my [ __ ] life don't you see the
[ __ ] and then some like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and then now I know why kids do crazy
[ __ ] like kill themselves and all that
after a breakup cuz that was her bra was
suicide free volatile dude I was man so
my friends come over and then they know
what went on right so I'm all like I had
to [ __ ] pretend I did I wasn't crying
all day right because I'm a tough boy
and then they come over we're gonna go
race cars and [ __ ] we jump in the car
you know they actually were very as like
as thug as we were they were very
supportive man they were like as cool
man like it's coolest talk about it like
whatever they're like girl [ __ ] happens
man they try to immediately try to hook
me up with another girl get me laid all
this stuff like they were my boys dude
and all I want to do was her and we're
about to go go go on the freeway a race
and then
I remember they turned and it was
getting too close to her neighborhood
uh-huh and I was like I can't do this
like we're getting to you were so
[ __ ] hurt anything about it you just
like not do it man I told him like can't
we take another route like [ __ ] and then
they're like what's going on it's like
we can't go this way man she lives out
here man
they're smoking weed Oh like give me
that [ __ ] joint and I'm all taking a
[ __ ] hit I'm not giving that joint
back I was like turned and then Dave
there it was so funny because I treated
her street in her neighborhood as if the
closer I was getting the more I was
dying I was so [ __ ] dramatic but it
was a [ __ ] radioactive like spill
we gotta get out of here man [ __ ] for
tonight as [ __ ] like we gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here
and then so and the homies were so dope
that they [ __ ] busted a u-turn in the
middle of the street it's [ __ ]
killing it man
yeah [ __ ] this do is Uther [ __ ] it
like they they got away like we just
robbed a bank that's [ __ ] funny man
and we took a longer route to the
freeway well how did you get over that
man I didn't know how like it would hit
me out of nowhere
for about a year straight I gotta know
where my heart would just start aching
I'm like oh I couldn't go to school I
couldn't do man I couldn't do like
regular gang [ __ ] anymore my heart was
so broken they're like hey man you want
to go jump some fools and I'm like
[Laughter]
that's so stupid it was back then it's
like hey man I don't want to cheer you
up let's go shoot people now is that so
you know be like oh you just picture
them like hey man you want to go
graffiti this place up yes like I redid
I wrote her name you know there's people
up there who have never had their heart
broken before and they just got to be
with one price I tell us scenario I was
like you've never had your heart broken
ever and you never will because I'm not
gonna leave her I was like you're
[ __ ] lucky
Oh cuz getting your heart broken is of
[ __ ] I would never wish that upon my
worst enemy because it's like how I used
to describe it was it felt like my heart
sank into the middle of my stomach
stomach would turn and it's in its young
heartbreak yeah well that shit's in my I
know every bride midnight song dude this
because I used to [ __ ] make these
mixtapes and I would just listen that
[ __ ] in my car and then remember I would
just be in my ride crying my eyes out
dude
non-stop when I when I got dumped I went
into this part I told my best friend at
the time I told him we're in we're
sitting on top of his [ __ ] hoopty ass
Nissan Sentra eating this burger and I
just started crying into this [ __ ]
Wendy's disgusting and then I took his
Bryan Bryan midnight mix CD and I just
started playing that [ __ ] non-stop over
and over and over the music man the R&B
helped me out so much
dude man there's I know all those odds
of that first [ __ ] heartbreak yeah
and it's crazy because that heartbreak
lasted a while because I think I was
trying to get back with her just like in
your case but for me I was like for a
whole year because yeah she was my best
friend as well
oh so you were able to talk to her I we
were friends and we were kind of talking
to her once in a while yeah we had to
end it I was getting too obsessed here
same here like it was just like website
I kept on hoping that something was
gonna happen from yeah and girls are so
sweet that don't never tell you straight
up yeah and guys are so stupid
we'll take that as a hope yeah you know
like girl will be like well maybe we can
stay friends and in my head I'm like
there's a chance I just got to be better
she just wants me to be a better man and
I could [ __ ] get her back yeah it just
never worked out and you know even
looking back at it now there were signs
that she wanted to leave you know that
wasn't working out and even for me too I
knew that we weren't working out but I
just was trying to force something that
wasn't there you know for me that ass
was good we had a long-distance
relationship and I was at UCR and she
was in Davis
I'll ask tough and so you know we would
see each other every now and then and we
I would you know take the train to where
she would take the train to me and I
look back at it now is she didn't if she
didn't dump me and we didn't break up
I think that was my biggest growth
experience was the fact that she left me
was from then on I got to real really
look at a mirror and say like bro you're
a [ __ ] loser
yeah I didn't know I was I didn't think
I was a loser though there's this time
that's crazy but I mean you were older
cuz you're in college right oh yeah so
this went down when I was 16 damn dude I
wasn't [ __ ] old loser so so I didn't
have the thoughts to help me realize a
lot of [ __ ] yeah it was difficult it
took me like a year afterwards where I
was still I think like I was still in
love with her and I was still trying to
be like friends with her but then there
was a point where I remember I stopped
being in love with her and it was this
time where I was trying to play it cool
like you know be a really funny guy and
trying to be a good friend to her and
just kind of act like I didn't care
about it that way and I was just acting
out doing dumb [ __ ] cuz I did a lot of
stupid [ __ ] you know and she just looked
at me one day she goes you know what
you're really [ __ ] annoying and she's
never said that to me before I was like
what do you mean a man like me
she was like you're just you're annoying
me and I'm like oh and I [ __ ] [ __ ]
hurt me and I was like yeah before we
break up this is not this is after I
break oh oh you're after and I was like
she's never called me annoying before
this is the first time I annoyed her I
remember I stopped and I went home I was
pissed a little bit because she kind of
said that fucked-up [ __ ] to me by the
same time I was like oh you are annoying
dude I was like what's wrong with you
because you're a too obsessive on I was
obsessed I was like what are you
obsessed with like number one she's not
that dope number two like you're [ __ ]
I was like 20 at the time I was like
you're 1920 now bro move on like what
the [ __ ] are you doing and then from
that moment on it's when I really
started separating our friendship I
would hit her up every now and then and
then you know things became really cool
and there was a moment where I realized
that she literally had no more
all over me was when she was going out
with somebody else and then you know we
went to the same Community College
together and then when she came in this
is like she came in before we went to
because I would carpool together we
became decent enough where we could
carpool with each other's friends and
then she goes hey so I broke up with
another guy and just out of nowhere she
told me that and I was like you're gonna
rebound and then so I just sat there
looking at her I was like so so yeah
cousin why are you telling me that she
was no I just wanted to let you know
like you know we're split up cuz even
though they were still together we were
friends we would flirt a lot cuz we've
always had a flirtatious friendship
before we got yeah and so I was like
well why are you why are you telling me
that and then she goes I just wanted to
let you know she goes maybe I'll try
being single you know kind of playing it
off and I was like I looked and I
started laughing again [ __ ] and she was
like why are you laughing I was like you
have not been single since the date
since we've been friends you've never
been single once you are somebody who's
incapable of being single you always
need somebody there for you and then she
got pissed you know she was like Alyssa
did she show you up and she's like I'll
show you how single I am nice staying
single for a week exactly so like a
couple weeks later she got together with
the guy that she was interning at this
vet clinic which she was working at
which means that she already had like a
flirtatious relationship with that guy
or some habitual relationship exactly
and the guy that she was with after me
was somebody that was my really close
friend and he was hitting on her while
we were together oh so she's like she's
a homie hopper you know she consistently
homey hops all the time yeah and she's
already developing other relationships
as she's with somebody else cuz even
when they were together we broke up and
I'm her ex-boyfriend he we were flirting
with each other all the [ __ ] time
damn like she would come over as we were
kickin it and we would like watch movies
together or something and they're
together and he said he was cool with it
which I don't know why but she would
come over and she was like fall asleep
on my lap and I wasn't [ __ ] while
watching movies and [ __ ]
constantly in need of validation yes
evil and that's when I was like oh [ __ ]
David you had the upper hand now she's
not in control you're actually in
control of the situation and I think
that moment is she didn't call me
annoying and basically she was calling
me a loser I would have never realized
how much of a [ __ ] loser I was and
then from then on like my life started
to change she was my biggest life lesson
because you were such a loser you needed
you
prized her mm-hmm and she would walked
all over you and went for another guy
that wasn't giving her attention that
she wants validation from exactly I
couldn't I couldn't [ __ ] see it too
and it's not like she ever had bad
intentions but that's just once again
that's the type of guys that have been
around her so that's what she's used to
so it's not really her fault either
yeah so I just had to look back and
that's when I started doing a [ __ ] ton
of stand-up I started doing I I just
dated a lot more I wasn't afraid of more
experiences in my life just I started
collecting all these stories that was
helping my stand-up a lot yeah because I
wasn't living just for one human being
anymore
I was like oh man like dude you're not a
[ __ ] loser anymore that's why they
say that whole self self-love self-worth
all that [ __ ] is important before you
get into a relationship
oh yeah it's dangerous for young people
like kids high schoolers like they don't
even know themselves yet they don't love
themselves they get into a relationship
that [ __ ] hurts oh no no what the [ __ ]
to do if you don't have good parents to
teach you and walk you through that [ __ ]
that shit's like oh man I don't even
know how to help my teenage son walk
through because I just got to be like
you gotta have just feel the pain dude
and it'll it'll pass yeah and then it's
kind of good I mean I've been through
several good breakups heartbreaks and I
would say it caught it's it's for great
comedy material because I did not learn
my [ __ ] lesson I am a dramatic
[ __ ] drunk like when it comes to all
that you're passionate did I think it
our passion a guy you like that feeling
I think so man but the thing is I think
I've been burned so much I lack the
ability in my last relationship in my
last few relationships actually to show
the good side of the passion mmm so I
you'll I'll have the when it's too late
passion when it's when it's anger and
and like whatever but like I think now
I'm pretty ready cuz I'm unlocked to be
able to just explore all options you
know cuz I'm not really afraid to get
hurt anymore yeah I think I'm past that
stage cuz there was a stage when I
didn't believe in love and that's
probably because the multiple breakups
that I've had that I'm like I don't want
to go through that pain again it was
[ __ ] brutal yeah but now I'm more
older I feel like I could manage
paying better cuz it's gonna go it's
gonna happen you know but he's [ __ ]
playing music over a phone
bet [ __ ] it is right there is hilarious
dude that's a danger boy [ __ ] is he
looking like a danger boy that's a baby
boy being and then you the funnier part
is hiding it I don't what a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] you are I remember I was
in the backseat of a [ __ ] car I had a
gun in my lap we had some weed right and
we're smoking and umm I literally
started crying like like hiding crying
like my eyes were [ __ ] drooping right
and I'm out here like not even caring
about what's going on in the moment like
we're driving fast got a gun on my lap I
don't care all I care about is I want
her back in my life Glock in your lap
and some bleep right my eyes are just
drooping and I'm all like I'll give this
all up I'll give it all up for her you
know like I'm like tearing up like a
little [ __ ] that's [ __ ] funny man
and it's it's the contrast is hilarious
like we're out here okay we went to go
race cars and [ __ ] and in my head I'm
like I hope I die tonight so then I go
on the [ __ ] news or she regretted she
regretted see thing is stupid [ __ ] like
that that's why I'm like young love man
you do some stupid [ __ ] I meant people
exhibit those behaviors so much a buddy
of mine just went through a breakup and
as he was telling me about what the girl
was doing I could even ask him I because
you know him I literally called
word-for-word everything she was doing
and why and he was like dude are you
like a Oracle I was like nah that's
because she's exhibiting child behaviors
like like high school behaviors like for
example it would be like on some [ __ ]
like like oh well you should I want you
to leave the house and you know he'll be
like oh well I already packed my stuff
and I left so I'm gonna gonna find a
place and then she blows the [ __ ] up he
knows why did I understand why she blew
up I was like you know why she blew up
is because she wanted the option tell
you to get the [ __ ] out and you took
that from her and so she wanted to have
that power and
what does she say she goes I was really
mad because you took that away from me
and I was like that's some childish [ __ ]
but didn't she tell him to get the [ __ ]
out so this was afterwards I guess she
had some time to think about whatever
what happened before them and then she I
was like I literally told her that is
the childish move because she wanted the
power of Kenya and you took that from
her anymore how did you know that I was
like because I've seen this before a
million [ __ ] times just typical
behaviors of people who haven't really
like faced hardships like that yeah they
just want to lash out to hurt somebody
like in your case it's like I want to
[ __ ] die so you'll regret it yeah you
know I love man that's crazy well crazy
[ __ ]
we should do some more young love
stories I got a lot more matter
I haven't even shared this [ __ ] yeah is
this [ __ ] funny that's [ __ ] tight
well that wraps up this episode of the
genius brain podcast I know you guys
want to hear more but that's an hour in
like 17 or 10 minutes in Wow we went
pretty in yeah so you remember we can
you all can we you all can catch us on
on iTunes podcast Spotify stitcher any
type of audio platform
share the video give us a like and
thumbs up you can even like time tag the
parts that you thought were the best and
keep keep interacting man keep listening
and we'll be there with you every time
you travel every week Thursdays and
Sundays always Thursdays with Joe we're
popping we're cracking we're doing it
thank you very much
peace